tick tock with the platform tick tock  tick tock tick tock because i think  you're going to go where do you start  and the reason i went so ham four years  ago on tick tock was i knew what the  [ __ ] question is from everyone i was  like [ __ ] this could actually get people  going because we've gone through five  years of mature facebook and instagram  and it was like there was no fast tiktok  was the first thing that i saw that was  fast completely based on the merit of  the creative but the problem is a lot of  the people that got it fast didn't  necessarily go into it trying to get it  fast some of it was on a spoof on a lark  some heard me and talked about [ __ ] they  cared about and because they cared about  it and they were passionate about star  trek and they knew a lot about [ __ ]  spock and captain kirk it hit for the  people that also did